un salaire minimum à 15 dollars 25 la
plus forte augmentation depuis 1995
insuffisante pour certains trop
importantes pour les autres mais le
Conseil du patronat estime néanmoins
qu'on respecte ainsi l'équilibre du
salaire moyen québécois ce que
j'apparaissent équitable juste nous
regardons la réalité économique des
organisations qui n'ont pas
nécessairement toutes démarches de
manœuvre très élevée en termes de profit
ou même en terme de capacité de générer
des augmentations salaires de façon
importante pour évidemment pour les
propriétaires d'entreprises si cette
entrepreneur ne compte pas d'employés
aux salaires minimum les répercussions
se feront tout de même sentir quand on
voit une augmentation de 7% mais ça
donne un petit peu le temps pour les
augmentations de tout le monde ça va
représenter 2400 dollars supplémentaires
pour un pour une entreprise qui a un
employé au salaire minimum la Fédération
canadienne de l'entreprise indépendante
déplore que le fardeau financier des PME
augmente
les tarifs d'électricité de 6.5%, ça
s'ajoute à l'augmentation
et à la Régie des rentes du Québec puis
de l'autre côté on voit pas quelle
action sont prises pour diminuer la
pression des coûts sur le dos de nos PMU
qui sont encore fragiles c'est la poule
ou l'œuf un moment donné si ça a l'air
augmente les coûts de la marchandise
augmente c'est un cycle sans fin 73% des
PME canadiennes augmentent leur prix
lors des hausses de salaire minimum
selon Monsieur Vincent l'autre côté plus
l'entreprise est petite plus la
proportion qui augmente les prix
diminuent mais ils vont trouver d'autres
moyens puis donc ça fait plaisir pour
conserver une marge de profit
intéressante ce propriétaire n'aura
d'autre choix que d'augmenter ses prix
une réalité qui pourrait avoir des
conséquences sur son achat langage
faites-le dans le fond au niveau de vie
de personne augmente avec ça avec cette
hausse d'un dollar du salaire minimum
Québec fait aussi le pari de contrer le
fort taux de poste vacants dû à la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre ici
Louis-Philippe arsenault Radio-Canada
Québec